えーと まあ早速話が始まりますけど
まあ今日はいろいろ人間するこの予定というか
計画とかね まあそういうものについて
一応人生論を語りたいんです
別に予定って云々ということではなくて
計画って何の何なのかということではなくて
まあそのテーマに基づいて
人生ってどういうものかと
で お釈迦様の初期仏教の話から説明したいと思います
なんでそういう話になるかというと
一番最初に言いたいところは
やっぱり仏教っていうのは宗教として見てみるならば
で まあ例えばね まあ神様などをね
信仰する宗教のような場合は
まあどんな宗教の人々でも
世の中のことはね それほどうまくいくっていうことは信じてはないし
で その場合は じゃあ神に祈って神に頼っていればもう安全だよというふうな立場をとるんですね
あるいは希望通りにいかなかったら
まあいいんじゃないか
まあそれはどういうわけかって知っているのは神様だから
神様の気持ちだから まああんたまあ落ち着きなさいというふうな話をして
人々の心を  何といいますか
慰めてくれるんですね
例えば 大変な不幸なことがあっても
なんで私にそんなことになるんでしょうか
私は毎日欠かずに祈りしているんではないかといったところで
まあまあ そんな慌てなくても
まあそれはまああんた毎日神様にお祈りしているんだから
それは何か神様がお考えになっていらっしゃるでしょうと
ですから まあ自分でそんなに気にしなくてもいいんではないかというふうに言われると
まあ大体心っていうのはそうでしょうかと
そうですよということで落ち着きますね
それから まあまあ 他のそんなに絶対的な神というものは信じてない場合はね
で この厳密に神様を信じる宗教っていうのはいくつかあっても
神は信じてるんだけど
まあまあなんかちょっともやもやではっきりしない人々の場合は
まあ何か何かお守りとかね
何かに頼って 自分の身の安全
人生の安全というものは図っちゃうんですね
皆様に分かりやすいんだから言いますけど
例えば日本の車だったら
必ずしも交通安全のお守り
御札がついてるんですね
それは批判的に言うんではなくて
皆様よくまあ使っているもので
いわゆる絶対的な神というものはもう頑固と信仰している民族ではありません
だから まあそこら辺にある何かを
まあそのその仕事に応じて
もう安全対策としてお守り
御札などなどを使ったりもします
で 時々この星占いか八卦占いとかね
何か占ってみてどうでしょうかというふうになってきて
まあ占いはうまく出たんだからとかね
今日は御籤はもう大吉でしたよとかね
まあそういう気持ちでも
まあ心の安定を探している場合もありますね
ですから そういうようなことは日常茶飯事で
人類は大体誰でも分かりやすくだからやっていることで
これはないということは言えないんです
そういうことだから まあそういう自分で立てというお釈迦様の教えから
その問題どういうふうにしますか？という
いわゆるなんで地球上の人類は誰でも何かに頼っていますかと
例えば共産圏の国々の場合でも
もう完璧に否定していましたからね
そういう神秘宗教などなどはね
インチキということで
それでも一般人の心の中で
ものすごくこのその必然性が湧いてくるんですよ
隠れてでも何かお守りしよう
お守りではお祈りしようではないかと
ですから 一旦共産主義の力が弱くなってくると
ものすごい爆発的にボンと宗教っていうのは飛び上がっちゃうんですね
ということは 心の中でずっとこの必要ということはあったわけなんです
だから昔からもうあって
今までこの 21 世紀になっても
我々の心に何かに祈りしたいと
何かをお守り欲しいという気持ちがあるんですね
ですから それは人類にあるもう一つの問題なんですね
それどういうことかというと
やっぱり不安なんですよ
いろんなことについて不安というのは必ずあります
それで何かにチャレンジして
何かをする場合はうまくいくでしょうかと
どうでしょうかという
そのもうそれも不安という不安なんですけどね
そのことも確実にあるんです
何一つ物事は これはもう 100%うまくいきますよという保証っていうのはないんです
ですから まあそこら辺でもう何かに頼っちゃうということは出てくるんですね
ですから このお釈迦様が自分の足で立ってなさいとかね
いろんなことに もうもうあまり余計なものにね
頼るなよというふうなことは言ってるんだけど
我々の心にはこの不安という問題は確実にありますよ
商売もうまくいくでしょうか
ないかとかね 健康でいられるかないかとかね
そういうことっていうのは必ずしもあります
ですから 最終的な答えとして
お釈迦様が考えたのは
この心の不安を 心にある
この不安定な状態 それ直しましょうということであって
そうすると まあまあどうったことはないと
では そういうことなんですね
だから必ずしもあなたの希望通りに
こういう風にすれば 100%うまくいきますよというふうな
この万能薬みたいな方法を教えたわけじゃないんです
まあ例えば神々がいっぱいいて
ABCD とかね  Z までいるとしたらね
ある人は A の神様を信仰して
ある人は B の神様 そこの中で一人が X でも Y でもいいんだけども
絶対的で何でも叶ってくれる神様みたいなものがいるならば
みんなそちらに頼ればいいことで
でも世の中でいろんな神々にみんな頼ってお祈りしてはいるんですけど
よく客観的に見るとみんな同じなんですよ
アッラーという神様を信仰したっても
ジェホバという神様を信仰したっても
そこら辺の他の神様を信仰したっても
人生はみんな結局同じなんですね
成功する人がいて しない人がいる
大変不幸に遭う人もいて
そうでない人もいるとか
病弱になる人もいて 大変元気にいる人もいるし
これが宗教あるかないかということに関係なく普通にあることで
そこでお釈迦様が それは全部なくなって
完璧に物事 100%うまくいく方法
こういう方法があるんだよというふうに言ったならば
それはそれでいいんですけど
そんな方法はおっしゃってないんです
その代わり おっしゃっているのは
そんなことは放っておいて
世の中のことはね あなたの心の不安をね
そこは自分で管理できるんだから
そこら辺なんとかしましょうと
そうすると この各個人にどんなものにも立ち向かうというか
その勇気が出てくるんですね
だから失敗は怖いよと
失敗したくないと言っちゃうと
心が弱くなっちゃうんですね
そうすると行動ができなく
失敗したらどうしようか
どうしようかとかね 初心者の車の運転みたいなことで
事故を起こしたらどうしようか
どうしようかと事故を起こしちゃうんですね
もうものすごい心配しすぎて
ですから この そういうことじゃなくて
心が安定しているんだったら
まあ失敗しても成功だっても
そんな別に怖くないという状態でいられるならば
心は安定するんですから
お釈迦様は特別に心を育てるということを教えちゃうんですね
ですから ご利益の秘訣ではなくて
安定した清らかなしっかりした心を育てる方法
で 他の宗教になってくると
まあ心のことも言いますけど
あまり重点はそちらに置かないで
やっぱり社会で成功することやらご利益のことを話したりするんですね
そうすると私たちもなるほどすごいと思って
そちらにもうもうもう食ってかかって飛びかかっていくんですけど
だからといって そんな100%成功している人っていうのはないんです
そういうとこは基本的にありますので
まあ仏教はそういういろいろ生きる上で
我々にどのような提案をしているかっていうことを勉強してみた方がいいと思います
それからこのまあ信仰の宗教ではございませんので
実践の宗教ですから これはまあ教えているものはコツコツと毎日実践してみないと
うまく効き目が出てこないんですね
だから祈りみたいなものがないんだから
ただ仕事をしながら みんなと話しながら
いろんな人生を生きながら
その中で実践できる方法っていうのは
まあ教えているんですよ
まあ例えば人間にはまあ仕事をしなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様というのは 仕事はどのようにすればいいかということであって
仕事をする前に 5分お祈りしなさいということじゃないんです
皆様方 イスラム教の国々に旅行にいらっしゃるでしょう
おそらく行ってみてください 12
時になったらどこにも誰もいないんです
お祈りに行ってるんです
だから突然 もう仕事真っ最中で 1 日 5回やってますから
もうみんなもう祈り お祈りしてるんですね
面白いことは その国々の飛行機に乗っても
その時のみんなこの全部仕事をやめて祈りしようとするんだから
ちょっと冗談じゃないと言いたいとこなんです
もし相乗しも じゃあ今お祈りの時間だから
じゃあお祈りしようと
まあそれはだけはもうもうやめさせ
やめているんです 私は一回見たんだけど
やっぱり中のサービスしているね
まあ方々はまあそちらもイスラム教でちゃんと全部体もう隠して女の人々いるんだけど
それはもうやめなさいと
みんなに迷惑やと言って
まあやめさせたんですけど
まあ同じ宗教同士だからよかったと思いますよ
他の宗教の人では こんなことやったら困ると言っちゃったら
もうどうなることかわからないんです
だからそういうふうな
この感情的な何かでみんなこの団結させちゃって動かすというのは
仏教はあまりではなくて
全くそれは良くないと
人間というのは集めたら恐ろしい組織で
何するかわからないものだから
そうやってこの何かに
得体知らない何かに概念を入れて固めてもらっちゃうと
まあいいところよりも危険の方が多いんですよ
それよりはバラバラで自分の意見があって
まあいた方が 害は少ないんですね
例えば誰かを殴りましょうと 3
人で話したっても 3人も意見バラバラだったらなかなか団結して拉致できないんですね
何回言っただけで はい
やりましょうという状態だったら
これはすごい危険なんです
なぜかというと 人間の心というのはそんな信頼できるものではありません
まあそういうことで お釈迦様の道っていうのは
この仕事をする前に 十分
二十分 三十分 これこれやりなさいとかね
例えば我々は習慣的に朝やら昼夜いろいろお経なんかもやったりはするんですけど
それはもうお釈迦様がした決まりじゃないんです
一つも そういうこの形式的な決まり
一つも決めてないんです
出家している人々には厳しく
ものすごい厳密にいっぱい決まりありますけど
それでもこの一日時間なくなるようにとかね
そういうのはないんです
で 月二回ぐらい集まればいいんだと
月二回だから 別にそれはまあ
そこら辺のお坊さんたちに簡単に集まるし
それで例えば髪の毛を剃らなくちゃいかんということがあるんですね
それにしても お釈迦様はまあ月一回ぐらいで十分だと
毎日ピカピカと剃らなくちゃいけないってことになっちゃったら
それに毎日かなり儀式的に時間かかっちゃうんです
ですから もういくらか伸びたってお前はいいやと
好きというか この月 2
月 2月に一回だと思いますけどね
結構伸びますよ そうするとあまり伸びすぎちゃうと格好悪いんだから
この指の2つの節というんですか
その長さ超えちゃうともう
剃りなさいと だからまあ随分この楽に
まあ出家は修行することだからね
まあそこら辺に重点を置いて
この形式 しきたり そういうものに人を束縛するということはないんです
でも人間というのは形式やらね
こういう儀式というのはすごい好きだからね
まあ仏教にも テーラワーダ仏教にしたっても
いろんな儀式とかね 習慣とかはまあどんどんどんどん入ってはいるんで
そういうものには時間は取れる
取ってしまっちゃうし
仕事を休んできて その儀式やらなくちゃいけないことにもなっちゃったりするしね
まあそういうことはあるんだけど
それはお釈迦様が決めたものというではありません
一つも ですから お釈迦様は我々のおっしゃっているのは
朝起きて寝るまで我々は何かしなくてはいけないことであって
それがどのようにすればいいかということですからね
わかりやすければ包丁を使わなくちゃいけない
それで包丁の使い方を教えるだけのことで
それで何か都合が悪いことでもありますかね
我々は包丁を使わなくちゃいけない
それでお釈迦様がじゃあ包丁の使い方を教えますよと
それはたとえ話で言うんであって
別に経典に包丁の使い方はないんですけど
まあ誤解しないでください
そこである人がまあ仕事は運転手やと言ったら
ではあなたに運転の仕方を教えますよと
でお釈迦様は だから別に技術を教えるんではなくて
もう 一つありますね 運転するときはどんな心構えでしょうかと
技術は技術の学校で勉強しなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから 決して人生に負担にならないんです
その負担にならない生き方を教えているんです
そういうことで このテーマもまあ考えた方がいいと思います
それでまあ予定というものは計画でしょうしね
で なんかわからないんだけど
私たちはずっとこの計画なしに何一つもできないんですね
計画しないできちんと段取りを取らないと
何一つもできない のは人間なんです
だから我々はもう人間というのは昔からもういつでもいろいろ計画を立てるんです
それでしきたりなども生まれてきたのは
その弱みなんです 弱みというならば
弱みかどうか分かりませんだけどね
例えば宗教的な習慣でも
夏になってくるといろいろお祭りしなくちゃいけないとかね
まあお盆ちゃんとやらなくちゃいけないとか
いろいろ習慣が出てくる
そうするともうそれに合わせて我々は生き方を変える
だから宗教のいろんな諸宗教の中にあるいろいろ儀式
儀礼なども この人間に計画が必要だから出てきたものなんです
何かセットを決めてあげないと
人間はまとめてくれないんですね
ですから 何かこの枠を基準を規則を決めて
って置いておくんですね
だから私たち現代人がこの作る
立てる計画 いろんなプラン
プランですか いろんなプラン
プランとか計画とか予定と
それから昔からいろんな宗教による儀式
儀礼とは大して変わりがないんです
同じものなんです すごい会社のもうもう
もう管理のレベルの人々がね
会社の経営についていろんな計画を立てる
ものすごい分厚いもう文章を作って
今年の計画はこれだよとかね
それはすごく言われて
もうすごい研究してきちんと作った計画ですよとか
会社のためにとか それと
いつでしたっけ？京都の灯籠流しとかありますね
何月か もう夏になってからやると思いますけどね
その日になったら灯籠を流しましょうとか
それと違いますか？とか
違わない 同じことなんです
全く同じことで あれはただ昔からそういう風に決めてやっただけで
だからまあ そういうふうに決めているんだから
その日にちになってくると
みんなそのあれをなんとか作って
川でもう流しちゃうんです
お盆が終わったところで
会社にしたっても もう作った計画通りに 1月どうしますか
2月どうしますかとかね
その通りに動く だから別に考える必要ないんです
すべて人間というのは何か決まっておかないと不安で動かない
言うことを聞いてくれないというところがあるんです
だから何かノルマでもぶん投げらないと
投げてあげないと社員たちが動いてくれないんです
会社にも社員に まああんた方はリラックスして
まあ適当に頑張ってくださいと言っちゃうと
何一つもやってくれない
それで実現できないぐらい
もうものすごい難しい
もう高い数字のノルマなんかつけちゃうんです
いろいろチャートまで作って
今週の売り上げは誰さん何さんがどれぐらいですかとかね
そういうふうな精神的ないじめまでしたりして
それも一つの儀式なんですよ
宗教儀式と同じことで
それで月に一回集めて
今月の成績発表とかになってくると
みんな神経質になってもう顔を真っ青にして聞いてるんだから
社員たちが だから宗教儀式と全然変わり違いますかね
同じことです だから ちゃんとそのしきたり
決まりを守らなくちゃいけないかと思って
一生懸命苦労して仕事をする
ですから この覚えておいてください
この古くから伝わってくる
このいろんな宗教にある儀式
儀礼とかね そういうものと
生贄まででもね そういうものをと
我々現代経済社会でやっている計画的な生き方とはそんな変わりがない
学校に至っても もう何から何まで計画
計画 計画 しきたり 規則で
例えば日本なのに日本の会社に行く場合は
西洋人の服を着ていなくちゃいけないんでしょうね
ネクタイをつけなくちゃいけないと
それも一つの儀式なんですよ
何でもいいやと思ったらどうするか分からないんだと
心配やと それで見てください
結局このしきたりが優先になって
人間の存在が小さくなる
例えば会社なんかは自分好きな普段着というかね
好きな服を着てくださいと
なかなか会社それ決められませんね
その意見だけはあったんです
そんなに厳しく このもう色やらネクタイの色やら何から何まで決めつけるよりは
それぞれ今豊かな社会でしょうし
いろんな服もあるでしょうし
ですから 自由に まあそれなりにおしゃれして来たってもいいんじゃないかなという意見はあったんだけど
そのまま意見のまんまで流産するんです
ちゃんともう元気で そこは一つ行動にはなってこないんですね
ですから この 一つ決まり決めちゃうと
決まりのために生きているということになっちゃうんです
それはすごい残念なことですけど
危険なことなんです だからそれ宗教に合わせてみると
いろいろ宗教で儀式 しきたり決めちゃうと
人間はどうでもいいことになっちゃって
宗教で決まったものは実行しなくちゃいけないんだということになっちゃうんですね
それで人が殺したりところまでも行っちゃうんですね
だからこのそこら辺はおかしいんです
計画なしに生きていられないというならば
そこまではいいんですけど
やがて計画がもう神の言葉になってしまって
計画のために生きていなさいということになっているんですね
だから人間が作った計画がやがて人間を支配する
今 我々はそうやって計画に支配されて生きているんです
それが仏教的じゃないんです
計画立てるなということじゃないんです
あの SF 映画など皆様知ってるでしょうに
今 ロボットやらね もういろいろ何でも自動化するんだよと
オートメーションにするんだよと
それで家の仕事やらもう何でかんでまあロボット作って
まあ大変優れたコンピューターやら IC を開発して
それで何でもまあプログラム組まなくても
ロボット自分のプログラム自分で組めるようにしようではないか
そういう SF 的な話なんですけど
そうするといくつかの映画出ているでしょうに
結局コンピューターたちが
ロボットたちが人間を抑えて支配して
もう殺してしまっちゃうと
というアメリカの映画もいくつかありましたからね
やっぱりその映画を作る人にしても
実際に世の中でないものは想像できませんだから
それをあの 台本書いた人やらスクリプトを書いた人々やら
世界を見て この西洋の世界
アメリカの世界を見たら
結局計画のために生きているんではないかと
人間のために作るコンピューターを作ったんだけど
次にコンピューターのために人間が変えなくちゃいけないんで
自分を変えなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそういうふうなことになって
大事なこれ人間が大事なんですけど
そこを忘れてしまうんですね
だから今の世界を見たら
経済発展とかなんとか言いながら
経済発展が大事なことであって
人間はどうでもいいと
決まり守ることは大事であって
この守られる側の苦しみは
そんなことはもう関係ないんだと
だから落ちこぼれやらもういっぱい出てくるんですね
そうすると人間逆にまた不幸になっちゃうんですね
だからこの計画性の出てくる最初に出てくる問題はそれなんです
人間が人間のために作ったものは
人間をいじめる 支配するものになってくるんです
犬が人間に番犬頼むような
ちゃんと守ってくれと
俺が寝るんだぞと という状態になっているんです
だから犬に飼われている状態になっているんですね
犬を飼って番犬にする状態で始めたんだけど
逆に犬に飼われている
実際にはありますからね
犬が飼ったら 犬によって全部自分の人生設計を変えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃいますからね
だから仏教というのは智慧の教えだから
これは知的な生き方ではないんです
やっぱり自分の立場を
自分の幸せというのは失ってはいけないんです
たとえ動物飼ってもいいんだけど
だからといって動物のレベルまで
人間の人格まで落とさなくちゃいけないと言ったら
これはあまりにも残酷なおかしいことなんです
ですから この私は人間で
一匹の動物も飼ってあげるんだよと
自分の幸せ 自分の生活
自分の立場っていうのは
やっぱり守りながらやらなくちゃいけない
いけないことなんですけど
だからそこら辺気をつけましょうと
計画立てることをやめましょうと言ったっても
これは人間には無理なんです
計画立てないでやるということは無理なんです
じゃあ今日は明日朝早く出かけましょうと
人ぐらいで話してみてください
じゃあ明日早くなんとか場所で駅の前の喫茶店で会いましょうと
何時に集まると思いますか？集まりませんよ
だから時半と言わないと
あるいは時と言わないと
じゃあ明日時に駅の前の喫茶店で集合して
次の何とかしようという風にぎっしりとしておかないと
じゃあ早くからやりましょうと言っても絶対無理でしょう
それぐらいのことは誰でもわかってます
それが人間なんです だから計画立てること
予定を作ることはもうもう悲しいことで
もうどうにもならんことなんですね
ですから この計画を立てるとうまくいく
ですから 何でも計画した方が悪くないんです
何から何までぎっしりと
でもそちらへ出てくる危険というのは
何から何まで計画を立てると
自分が計画のために生きている奴隷になっちゃうんです
自分の自由と心の安らぎ
楽しみというのは全部消えちゃう
それで自分が じゃあ私は毎日もう今日から時に起きますと自分でちゃんと計画を立てる
そこである日時に起きられなくなっちゃうと
まあ大変 その人が自分を責めたりする
それから次から次へともう狂ってしまう
なんかすごい悪いことをしたような感じにもなる
それはもう計画に支配されている状態なんですね
とにかく早く起きましょうと思ったら
一度もまた実行しない
やっぱり 6時に起きましょうというふうに決めなきゃ起きられませんし
とにかく早く起きますと言ったら9時になる可能性もありますし
それでちゃんと 6時に起きるぞと計画されたところで
ある日なんとかできなかったならば
ものすごく自分を責めたりしてショックを受けたりするだけではなくて
その日の次の計画からもう全部狂ってしまっちゃうというのは人間の生き方なんです
それは動物たちの生き方と比べてみてください
何の計画もないんだけど
きちんとその日で その日でやらなくちゃいけないことはすごくうまくやるでしょうに
で 動物たちが例えば交尾をして子どもを作ると
うまく季節に合わせてあって
そのその動物に 子どもの頃はいっぱい餌がある時期に合わせてちゃんと産むんだからね
そうすると親たちがきちんとあっちこっち行って餌を持ってきて
持ってきて 自分の子どもたちに食べさせて大きくする
誰も教えてないんです
この時間になって この時期で
例えば冬交尾する動物いるんですね
それもちょうど春になってきていると
もう子どもを産むような計算でよくやってます
このもう動物も時々集めて会議とかやりますけどね
やりますよ よくよく私は見るのはカラスなんですけど
ちゃんと定期的に会議やるんです
よく見ているんですけど
何も聞こえますけど 何喋ってるかわかりませんですけど
とにかくそれぞれみんなもうよく喋ります
喋ってきちんと時間になってくるとみんな解散しますね
あまり喧嘩とかは見えませんですけどね
そこでうまく集まること
その決まった場所でうまく集まって
じーっと座っているカラスもいるし
よくしゃべるカラスもいるし
親分でかなり大きい声でみんなにしゃべるカラスもいるし
それであっちはもう大きくしゃべるんだけど
こそこそ 2人  3 3匹ぐらい
3和ぐらい別に喋ってる時もちょくちょく見えますけどね
それで終わったら みんなまああまり長い時間もやりません
大体人間の時間で言えば 1時間以内に終わりますけどね
だから私はこれ監視して見てみたんだけど
ちゃんと定期的にやってます
だから他の動物もそういうふうな
いろいろ家族制度がある動物はいるしね
社会制度ある動物もいるしね
そちらでは別に決まった計画はないんだけど
やっぱり計画通りにやってますね
だから動物の世界では計画に支配されているかどうかっていうことはちょっとわからないんです
じゃないと思いますけど
楽にいるんだからね ですから
人間にとってはそれはもう大変
まあ無理な話で 我々はもうなんとかなんとか考えて計画立てなくてはいけないんですね
だから我々は作る計画っていうのは
あくまでもこの自然発生じゃないんだから
６時に起きますということは
自然的な考え方じゃないんです
これは時計という機械
から考えるものなんですよ
自然の中だったら 大体人間というのは
この自然にこの太陽が出てくる
そこそこでもう目が覚めるんです
太陽が出てくる その時間になってくると
もうだいたい目が覚めます
ですから 冬と夏は自然的に言えば違うんですよ
冬だったら人間っていうのはまあ7時まででも寝ている可能性あります
で 皆さんは経験あるでしょう
夏になってくると あまりにも早く目が覚めちゃって
夜も寝れなくて ああ 大変だ
大変だ 泣いてるでしょうね
あれは泣くことじゃなくて
あれは自然なんですけど
夏ぐらいになってくると
もう7時になっても まあもうすごい明るいし
もう元気で活発的で活動したいんですよ
そこで夜ちょこっと寝ただけでまた目が覚める
目が覚めて外を見てください
ちゃんともう太陽が出ているんだから
これで人間っていうのは
この人工的な計画の中にいるんだから
昨日大変困ったもんだ
んでしょうか 3時半で目が覚めてなかなか寝られなくなった 3
時半でも4時になってくるともう光が見えてくるんだから
ちょうど時間に目が覚めているはずなんですけど
光がある時は働けっていうのは自然の決まりで
だからちゃんと自然の計画の通りに行ってますけど
私たちはそれに逆らってるんですね
それで光が当たらないようにきついカーテンなんかつけて
雨戸もつけちゃって もう真っ暗にして強引に変えてもう寝る
だからそういうふうに我々は機械に支配されていることになっているんですね
だから人間の計画っていうのは
ものすごい狂いしやすい
もうほとんど狂ってしまっちゃうし
それで計画を守ることで
もう大変で もう健康も損なうわ
もういろいろ幸せを破壊しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 幸せのために作った計画で幸せを破壊するということになるんです
それは一つ 仏教の基本的な論理なんです
幸福を目指す人々が幸福を壊す方法しか思い出せないんだ
それで幸福を壊す方法
幸福を目指す方法だと勘違いして頑張っている
それで結果としては 当然の結果として大変不幸に
苦しみになってしまいますよ
それである中部経典にあるところなんですけど
この人間がカーマ欲というものあるんですね
欲が大激しくあるんです
欲っていろいろありましてね
まあ財産欲しいやらね
家族が欲しいとかね 子供が欲しいとか
まあそういうまあ欲で生きてます
ですから欲があるんだから
普通どんな人でも まあ食べて楽に生きるためには
お金やら財産欲しい 幸せ生きるために
それで家族も欲しいと
それでまあ家族やら全部作る
それからお金儲からなくちゃいけないでしょう
そういうことで この経典にあるのは
それで人々が まあ給料がいいと思って
例えば軍隊に入ると 昔の軍隊というのはかなり厳しいもんでしたからね
行っていろんな人々と戦うんだと
戦争に行くんだと 行って槍にも刺されるわ
刀で切られるわ 象に踏まれるわ
それで敵軍が来ると あのいろいろなんて昔よくやったみたいですね
この油とかね 沸騰するかもう沸騰するんですね
して この塀の上なんか置いといて
軍隊来るとボーンともうかけちゃうんです
だからまあまあ そういう戦争実でしたからね
で そういうものをもう体にかけちゃうし
それでも火傷をするし
矢で撃つんだけど 矢の先はもう火をつけているし
そうすると線も燃えちゃうしね
それでものすごい残酷に苦しみを味わって死んでしまっちゃう
何のためかというと 家族を守るために行って
家族を養うために行って
結局自分まで苦しんで死んでしまうのではないかと
そこで欲があるんだから
母が父と喧嘩するんだと
母と子供は喧嘩するんだと
父と子供が喧嘩するんだと
親戚同士でも喧嘩するんだと
財産のために 豊かになるために
幸せになるためにやっていることなんですね
それでなれないのは当たり前なんだよ
やってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 幸せになりたいという気持ちがあるんだけど
例えば私は全部財産自分で取りたいと
ある人が思う 自分が幸せになるためなんですね
それで兄弟ともう戦うんです
敵に回ってずっと戦う
兄弟もまた戦うと それで財産はもう法律でちゃんと五分五分に分けることになったっても
もう半分ぐらいもう裁判に行ってるんです
残る半分が分けてもらわないと
最初からもう分けてもらった方が何のこともないんですけどね
それで分けられないものについてはもう裁判にするとか
そうやって欲があって幸せになりたいということがあって
結局持っているものを失ってしまうというのは人間の生き方ですよと
だからこの計画の世界にすぎたっても
同じことで幸せになろうと思って計画を立てて
それでもって幸せを失う
ということが世の中にある事実なんです
では 私たちはどうすればいいかということになります
まず最初に言って言ってましたから
この計画を立てるということ自体が別にもう
悪いわけじゃないんですね
いわゆる悪いと言ったっても
悪いかいいではなくて
なんか避けられない 何か避けられないことなんですね
そこでだからといって計画自体がそんなにすごいものではありません
それが必要である一つの人間の道具に過ぎないんですね
その価値が大事なんですね
我々は計画にすごい価値を入れて
人間の価値を減らしちゃうんですね
生きるということ 楽にいるんだという価値をもう減らしちゃうんですね
そこら辺気をつけてみれば
簡単に 学校の決まりは何のためにありますか？といつでも考えなくちゃいけない
それはすごい簡単に忘れる
決まり守れと そして子供たちが逆に何のためにある決まりか聞いたら
もうもうもう管理できない子供たちやと
問題児たちやと言って
もうカウンセラーのところに運ぼうとする
どちらが行くべきかといえば
やっぱり管理する側が行くべきやと思いますけど
だから 国の憲法から始めて
もう家の家族の中で母親が決まる決まりまで
全てもう計画なんですけど
全て何のためということ
それがすごく大事なんです
それをまず覚えておくこと
それからいつでもそれを思い出すこと
決まりだから守れということじゃないんです
なぜその決まりを作ったんでしょうかと
ですから 計画自体っていうのは
そういう目的がなくなっちゃうと
もう守る必要はなくなっちゃうんです
それじゃなくて もう年前に決めた決まりでも
厳密に守ろう守ろうとして
また不幸になるということは
まああんまりこの説法で私はもう言えない例いっぱいありますけどね
日本の社会を見ても もういい加減やめた方がいいんじゃないかなと
この法律はとかね もうよくよく感じるものあるんですけど
それでも頑固と守るぞと
何のためですか？と聞きたいところはいろいろあるんです
なかなか皆様方は気づかないみたいですけどね
まあ例えば まあ子供があっちこっち行って
いろいろなんか悪いことをして
もうもう見つかったとしますね
それで両親が子供に厳しい決まりを作る
外へどこへ行って遊んでも
きちんと 6時に家に帰らなくちゃいけないんだと
それは別に悪い決まりじゃないんです
それで まあ例えば子供はまあなんとか悪くても
後からもうものすごくおとなしくなっちゃって
いい子で育てて それでいろいろ
あの まあ例えば音楽をやりたくなったりしますね
で 友達と集めたら まあ 5時からやっぱりまあ 6時半までまあ練習するとかになっても
この子はやっぱり 6時に帰らなくちゃいけないんですね
で その場合は まあもう子はもう悪いことをするということはないんだと
もう今普通にもうちゃんと成長しているんだと
もう問題はないんだと
あの精神不安定な状態はもう消えちゃったと
わかったら あの 6時に必ず帰れという規則をもうそれで解除しないと
だから目的が達成したら
計画はもう関係なくなるんですね
それが人間やらないんだから
目的はもうどうでもいいんです
決まりだから守りなさいと
だから仏教っていうのは
仏教でも決まりいっぱいありますけど
仏教はいつでもこのいつでも進歩的で
もう何でも適当にもう考えながら考えながら変えて変えていってほしいと
だから世界の社会の進歩っていうのは
やっぱり壊してはいけないんですね
計画などを作ってしまっちゃうと
それを固定化して それに支配されるようになっちゃうと
社会が 1か所に留まるということになっちゃうんですね
そうすると必ずも破れて壊れてしまうんです
この世の中を見て お釈迦様
いろんなこのもう何百
何万 何百万年前のとかね
わからないほど古い古いもう社会にシステムについても語っているところがありますけどね
いろいろこの社会システムが壊れていくというところは
まあこの保守主義なんですね
一つ で いろんな何か決めて
その決まりの中にぎっしりと人々を束縛させようとしちゃうと
もうどうにもならなくなって
それを壊してしまっちゃうという
で 次のポイントに行きますけど
この 立てた計画はうまくいってほしいんですね
これも誰の普通の願いなんですけどね
うまくいかないと占いに頼ったりします
方角も考えたりする そういう迷信的なところまで行ってしまっちゃうんですね
で なんでしょうかね 方位学やらね
占いやら かなりもう徹底的に信じている人々います
ちゃんとあの なんとかの人からもうなんとか風水占いをしてもらって
まあそれからは大変収入も良くなって
もう家族の喧嘩もなくなって
子供も落ち着いてきたんだと
だから私はもう徹底的に信じているんだとかね
いう人々はいるんですけど
いくら言われても 私はそんなものは科学的な
きちんとした 客観的に見た正しい判決やとは思わないんですね
ちょっと常識あればね
風水占いしなくてもね
枕はどこに置いて寝た方がいいかくらいは常識でもわかると思いますけど
玄関はどちらにあれを周り見たらわかりますけどね
だからそれはしないんだからね
まあ誰か風水とかなんとかの人に行ってもらって
まあやりますけどね そういう人々もいい加減でね
何言うかわかりませんね
まあどうしてももうドアがつけられないところに
こちらにドアがなければいけませんとか言っちゃうと
自分の国ではまあ面白い話がありましてね
この人が死んだら遺体をお墓までお墓ではなくて
墓地まで持っていかなくちゃいけないんだからね
それで占い師を占ってあげるんです
西からその日にその日によってね
東を見て家から出ましょうと
あるいは西を見て 家の玄関はどちらに見ているかということを
また例えば家の玄関はもう東の方だったら
占い師がもう西を見て持っていくと
壁を破らなくちゃいけないんです
そちら壁だから一回話聞いたことはないんですけど
その占い師が言った方向はもうドアがないんです
それで棺をそこから外へ持っていかなくちゃいけない
です そうすると窓があって
窓を外して壁を破って
いくらか大きくして そこから苦労して苦労して棺を外へ出して
それからまた行列で持っていったと
だから なんでそこまで
無意味な笑えることをするんでしょうかね
だから 占い師の話を聞かないと何かうまくいかないんだろうというね
危険だよということなんですね
だから我々 人生のいろんなことを計画している途中でうまくいかない時は
そうやって神秘に頼っちゃう
それに仏教の答えは因果法則なんです
だからできれば お釈迦様がおっしゃっている因果法則を勉強した方がいいんです
だから 困ったことをみんな伝統的に考えるんだから
因果法則と言った途端
十二因縁ではないかと
無明から行が生じるとかね
特にもう仏教の学者というのは日本でたくさんいらっしゃいますからね
パーリ仏教の学者も日本にはたくさんいます
因果法則とは何でしょうかと聞いてみてください
必ずしも無明から行が生じるというところから始まると思います
それで私の話なんか あの人はなんか随分好き勝手なことを言うんだよと言う可能性もあります
そういうもうもう意見はあまりも対立するんだだから私は学問的研究っていうのは一切やりませんと
いさぎよくやめたんです
今もそれを自慢に思っているんです
博士論文とかいろいろ書いてると
なんてアホでしょうかとかね
これぐらい苦労したっても
これぐらいしか言えないで
それまた間違っているし
ですから この因果法則っていうのは何でしょうかね
それはどこにでもある普遍的な科学的な法則なんです
結果は原因によるものだよと
それが因果法則なんです
無明から行が生じるという
そればっかりいちいち勉強したっても
生きる上ではそれ役に立つんでしょうかと
それがこの修行する人々に
このもうもう悟りを開く前に智慧が開発してもらわないと悟れないんだから
この智慧の開発のために
真理の世界を理解するために教えているところであって
それは一つのアプリケーションだけなんです
ですから この結果は原因によるものだよと
それははっきりわかると簡単に計画を立てられます
計画って何なのかって
仏教的に言えば ある望む結果が想定します
こういう結果を望んでますよと
それでその結果を出すために
現れるために どんな原因そろえばよろしいかと
その原因そろうことが
この原因 こういうこういう原因だよと発見することが計画なんです
それを発見して じゃあそれからその原因をそろってみましょうと
その原因を適当にそろったところで
適当な結果が必ずしも出ます
狂うことはないんです
だから計画性っていうのは
この原因結果のことで
いつでも望む結果というものを考えてほしい
世の中の計画はそういうものじゃないんです
全部もう計画のために我々は生きているのであって
宗教の儀式儀礼とは何の変わりもないんです
飛行機の中でもお祈りしようと思っちゃうんだから
これは儀式儀礼であって
イスラム教のお祈りっていうのは
ちゃんと絨毯を敷いてメッカの方を見て
もうお祈りすることだから
だからちゃんと方位を教えてくれる
何て言いますか あれはコンパスとか持ってます
みんなでコンパスを開けたら
ちゃんとメッカはこちらにいますよ
ちゃんと数字出るんですね
イスラム教の人々が使う時計
時計でもそういう機能がついているんです
ちゃんとメッカがあるところはちゃんと示してるんです
だからどこにいてもメッカはあるところは知ってますけどね
でもね メッカはサウジアラビアにありますけど
地球の裏側にいると そこはどこを見てお祈りするんでしょうかと思い
思いたいんだけどね だから論理的じゃない
そこまで考えないんだよ
それでも放逸でこっちへ行ったら
もうどこか見てやってますからね
だって丸いんだからね
メカがあるところはこう裏回っちゃうと
こうやって自由に逆立ちして泳ぎをしないと
だからまあそういうふうにも儀式儀礼になってくると
もうバカバカらしくなっちゃって
もう大変なんですね だから
この仏教の因果法則を考えて計画を立てるということは
望む結果がありますよと
そのためにこの子の条件を揃えましょうということであるならば
決してこの何のためにということが忘れられません
だから我々は因果法則を無視して計画を立てようとする
だから予定が狂っちゃうと
みんなこの大変困ったりします
がっかりするところじゃなくて
もうもう本当に自殺する人は結構いるんだから
人生の予定やら全部狂っちゃったんだと
もう嫌やと言って自殺までする
そこまで不幸になるんですよ
それはみんな因果法則なんかもうひとかけらももう見ようともしない
だから因果法則自体何を教えてくれるかというと
これは物事っていうのは私の希望通りに行くわけでもないし
あなたの希望通りに行くわけではありませんと
ということは 自と他だから
もっと素朴に言えば 神様の希望通りにも行きません
物事は この神様を信仰している方々は気づいていないだけで
神様は希望して人類を創ったんだけど
神様の計画通りに動いていないんですね
信じている人よりは信じない人の方が多いんです
だからはっきりしていますよ
絶対的な もう何て言いますか
全知全能 全能の神だと言っては言ってはいるんだけど
神の希望通りの物事は行かないんです
どこでも だから客観的に見ればいいでしょうに
我こそ正しい神を信仰しているんだから
我こそ勝ちます 言ったっても負けっぱなしでしょうに
戦争して戦争して 戦争はもうずっとありますからね
大体仏教の影響はいくらかある国の人ほとんど少ないんだから
日本にしてもまあ他のね
そんなにあったっても早く
例えばカンボジアで激しく汚く
もう恐ろしい人殺しあったでしょうに
やめましょうと思ったら
すごい簡単にやめちゃったでしょうに
もうものすごい人を殺した人々も
恨みもなく もう今何のことなく生活平和で生活しています
まあ完璧な平和っていうのは成り立ちませんだけど
やっぱり日本のテレビで見たんだけど
なんかこのもうたくさん人を村人でね
いろんな人のことを言って言っていて
殺されて殺して殺して殺して
その人はもうもう報告するんですね
その人の報告によって
もうその村の人々もかなり死んでしまったみたい
殺されたみたいです で
今政権変わったところで
この人がこの村の大勢の何 100人も人々のことを報告して密告して殺したってことをみんな知ってるんです
でもその人はもう何もしません
誰も その代わりに その人が自分がものすごい悪いことをしたんだと
ですから それはもうちゃんと
あの 何て言いますか 罪滅ぼししなくちゃいけないんだと思ってもう全くもう村も全部離れて
山の中にどうかな ちょっと洞窟みたいなものを作って
その中でなんか行者みたいな生活をしているんですね
死んだ人々に仏教だからね
いろいろなことをして
回向したり 冥福を祈ったり
自分が一人で一生懸命
もう厳密にもう 聞いたらもう堂々と言う
私はそういうそういうふうなことをしましたと
ですから ものすごい罪を犯しましたと
だから自分がこれからは修行に入って
なんとかその罪をなくすように
なんとかしなくて そうすると他の人々もそれをよく理解して
私はもうなんときれいな人々だなと
いわゆる村人のこと 殺された被害者の側から見ればね
その被害者っていうのはいかに立派かと
ですから この 絶対的な誰かに誰かを信仰しているんだから
全ての物事うまくいくんだよと思っても
実際の世界を見るとそうはないんです
ですから 因果法則っていうのは
私の意見がその通りに行くということはありえないし
他の意見もその通りに行くということはありえないんです
これは自分と他人という個人個人の問題ではありませんと
こんなものは法則ですよと
私が雨が降って欲しくないと思っただけで
雨が降ってこないと思うのは
まあ若者いいところでしょうに
私が雪が嫌だなと思っても
今ちょっと暑いんだから
雪ぐらいちょっとふらっと降った方がいいいいんではないかなと思ったってもね
そうはなるわけじゃないでしょうに
じゃあそれが神様が決めて降らしちゃうんですかね
神様にそんな力あるんだったら
じゃあ一回だけでもいいんだから
真夏に雪降らしてくれと
地球上みんなお願いしたらどうですかね
そうすると聞いてくれるかもしれません
かなり耳が遠いんですけど
誰も怖くてそんなチャレンジまでしないんだから
私だったらやりますけど
神を信じる人も信じない人
みんな一斉に 1 日決めて
地球スケールで 今は一番簡単にできますからね
情報ネットワーク 世界中いっぱいにできていますから
じゃあお祈りしてみましょうと
真夏にその真夏が空いてるこの国に一回だけでもいいんだから
雪降らしてくれと できるかと
だからこのまあそんなもん
そんなこと言ったら それは神を侮辱することやとか
くだらんことを言う 侮辱じゃないでしょうに
全知全能だから それぐらいのこと
何にもないでしょうに
だから乱れてる人間をね
ちゃんと道に導くために
それぐらいのことをね
苦労したっても 慈しみの神だから何が悪いんですかね
だからそういうのは人間非科学的にいい加減で
感情で言うだけであって
物事っていうのは私の意見でも他人の意見でも行くわけじゃないんです
だから希望通りにいかないんだぞという仏教の教えは
それは頑固たる事実なんです
希望っていうのは私の主観だから
それでお釈迦様に文句言いたがるんですね
仏教は暗いやと 希望通りに行くようになんとかもう呪文でも唱えてくれるのはありがたいではないかとかね
何か護摩でももう護摩供養でもしてくれたらどうでしょうかねとかね
頼んだらやりますよ 私に頼んだらお金くれるんだったらやりますけど
自分では信じてないんですけど
それはお金必要です 説法は無料でしますけどね
インチキだったらお金必要なんです
ですから まあどうでもいい
うまくいかなかったらね
もうあなたの運が悪いとかね
あんたちゃんと心は掃除機で心を集中してね
きちんと参加しなかったんだから
私知りませんよ それはそれだけのことでしょうと
みんなそうやってこのこういうね
まあ人系の人々がみんなそうやって責任逃れでしょ
私たちみたいにすごい凶暴でチャレンジしてしゃべれないでしょうに
私だったら じゃあやってみなさいよ
もし間違いあったら言ってみなさいよ
はっきりとチャレンジしてしゃべってるでしょうに
これがこれ まあ １日  ２日
３日でもやってみなさい
もし結果がなければ ちゃんと言ってる
あるいは言っていることに何か間違いでもあるんだったら
堂々と言ってみてください
私はちょっと凶暴すぎてしすぎて
みんなもうチャレンジ攻撃したい気持ちあったって
なんか怖くてやらないということもあります
それは私の失敗で もうちょっとまあ穏やかにしゃべった方がいいなという気持ちはあるんだけど
どうも癖だからね これはもうどうにもならんことで
でもできればね 私はものすごい強烈な返事するかもしれませんだけど
それにめげずにチャレンジしても決して構いません
我々それは慣れてます
このお互いに対立して話し合うとかね
決して否定されたんだからといって落ち込むということは全くないんです
反対論 異論いっぱい出されて
まあどうしようもない
嫌だとかね 怒りになったとか
それはないんです あ それがみんな元気でよかったと
今日はかなりもうやりがいがあったと
という気分だけです ですからね
一応慣れてはいます 反論には
だからまあちょっと出してみたってもよろしい
とにかくこのこの責任逃れはしないんです
きちんと事実を語っているつもりですから
やってみてくださいと
もし異論があったら言ってみてくださいと
という状態で喋ってます
それは私の強さではなくて
お釈迦様の強さなんですけど
それでこの 因果法則に戻りますけど
因果法則をちゃんと理解する人が
私の主観はその通りに通るということはありえないんだと
それは自分のパイで気づきますから
全然気づくことないんだ
だって他の人の場合も同じことだから
誰の主観もそんな簡単にいくわけじゃないんです
例えばね 今の総理大臣たる小泉さんにしたっても
やりますと言うんだけど
かなり緊張していますよ
いろいろ反論があるんだっていう
それはちゃんと承知の上で
やらせてはくれませんということがね
ちゃんと知っています
だからその方がもうなんとかやりますという気持ちではいるんですけど
だからといって もうあれほどね
もう国民が賛成しているんだから
政治家の人々がね もう協力すればいいでしょうに
協力しないんだから ですから
それぐらい力ある人にしたっても
自分の主観が一方的にいくということはないんですよ
それは普遍的な事実なんです
そんなところが小泉さんのところか
もう絶対神様の意見さえもうまくいかないんだから
だから聖書を読んでも
他の宗教の聖典を読んでみたっても
口先だけは言います すべて私の希望通りにいくんだぞと
すべて私が決めるんだぞとかね
あんなものは脅しであって
子供だましやと思います
だって 実際に世の中を見ると
誰の意見もそんなうまくいってるはずがない
いってるわけじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様が因果法則として
これはまあ世の中にはいろいろ原因があって
その原因によって結果が出てくるんだよと
それは誰の意見というわけでもないんです
そこで人の意見というのは
主観というのはすごく弱いんだけど
一つの原因にはなります
だから無数の原因の中でたった一つなんです
だからまるっきり自分の意見は通らないかというと
そうでもないんです でも我々は
例えば 1万の原因の中でたった一つぐらい
一つ自分の意見 それだけ通ってほしい
それだけ通ってほしいというのはあまりにも論理的じゃないんです
だから計画を立てるということは
その因果法則によってやることで
この結果は望ましい結果だよと
その結果をになるために
こういうふうに条件をそろえばいいんではないかなと
それぐらいのことで考えているとがっかりすることはないんです
だから この計画の中で自分の主観
どれぐらい機能しているかと
そこをちょっと考えた方がいいんですね
例えば 20人集めて何かしようとする
どうしても人間が集めたら
一人がリーダーみたいなものは出てくる
そうでないとまとめないんだから
それでリーダーが出てきても
リーダーの意見というのは 20 分の 1 なんです
で リーダーが私はこういうふうなことを考えましたけどと言って
そればっかり通してもらおうと思っちゃうと
単なる独占 独裁ですね
そうすると 他の人々はとにかく壊してしまう可能性もあります
それで人ががっかりする
だから自分の意見はどんなパーセントかということは考えた方がいいんです
会社の社長が今年はこれぐらい儲かりますよと計画を立てても
自分の欲望だけでうまくいくわけじゃないでしょうに
だからそれは会社の社長の希望であって
それは一つの原因であって
またたくさん原因があるんですね
なんで自分の原因だけに
この 50%以上重みを入れるなくちゃいけないんですかね
それは 50%じゃなくて
1万分 1 万分の 1 ぐらいのことなんです
例えば その会社で 100人仕事をしているんだったら 100 分の 1 ですよ
社長の意見というのは
だって他の人と仕事をしなきゃうまくいかないんだから
それでじゃあ 100人も同じ意見になったとて成功しますか？しないでしょうに
会社って何か仕事をするところだから
それまた社会ということの反応によって成り立ちますから
自分が儲かるぞと儲かりたいんだからといって店を作って開いても
90%でお客さんの手に成功はね
お客さんが来るか来ないかということによって成り立つんです
挨拶 店を開いた人の気持ちじゃないんですね
だからその辺で我々のは
この科学的な 論理的に因果法則を理解しないんだから
みんながっかりするんです
予定が狂ったら人生まで狂ってしまっちゃうんです
だから因果法則を知ってるんだったら
予定が狂うということさえも成り立たないんです
本当はそれ非論理的なんです
なんで予定が狂うんですかね
おかしいでしょう 私は予定が狂うという言葉さえ成り立たない
予定が狂ったということは
非科学的で 因果法則を無視して私が作った計画がこの通りに行くはずでしたよと
その時点でもう完璧な非科学的な
もう原始人だから だから本当はまあもうちょっと知識人になるならば
予定が狂ったんだということさえも成り立たないんです
例えば何か予定があって
それはうまくいかなかった場合
狂ったとは言わないんです
こういう予定でしたけど
他の条件が出てきて変わりましたと
今日はハワイに遊びに行く予定でしたけど
あのまあ突然もう会社に呼ばれて
緊急事態で休暇を取り消されちゃったんだよと
予定が狂ってどうってそんなことはないんで
その場合は ただ 原因条件変わっただけのことだから狂わないんですよ
だから最初に言ったように
予定が狂った狂ったと思うこと自体もおかしいんです
だから常に私の意見は通りません
他の意見も通るわけじゃない
物事は法則によって動くものだと
それで自分には望む結果があるんだったら
ちょっとちょっとこの原因をちょっと
ちょっと何て言いますか
調整してみる 例えば糖尿病の人がどうしてもケーキを食べたくなっちゃうと
望む望む結果はケーキ食べたいという
でも自分にとっては食べてはいけないんだと
いけないことでもできないわけないでしょ
因果法則を知ってるんだったらできます
糖尿病であろうとも まあケーキは食べたいんだよという望みが出てきたら
じゃあケーキは食べたいんですけど
これ毎日パクパク食べるわけにはいきませんと
まあ一回ぐらいは このまあどうしても食べたいんだからね
これはちょっと気持ちが落ち着かないんだと
じゃあ一回食べるんだったらどうすればいいかと
じゃあ朝ご飯をパスして
ケーキにしますとかね
昼私は一応なんかこれ食べてますけど
じゃあこれはやめて ケーキ 1個食べてコーヒー飲もうかなとかね
そういう風に自分のことじゃない
体したっても体にしたっても
だから入る糖分と自分の出すインスリンならその計算がありますから
そこら辺でちょっと調整変えればケーキは食べられますでしょうに
全く食べられないというわけじゃないんです
あるいは糖尿病なんて
私は神様を信仰しているんだから
いっぱいケーキ食べて
まあ余分にお祈りしますよと
病気にならんようにとかね
そんなことはありえないんだからね
毎日 5分お祈りするんだけど
今日は 15 分にしますと
それでケーキいっぱい食べますと
病気にならないんだとかはありえないんでしょうに
だから普段無理と思うものでも
因果法則を知っているならば
いくらかは可能にする
ことはできます そのように考えると
我々にはやっぱりどうしても変えられないこともあると
例えばヒマラヤなんかを登ってみたいなとかね
地球の頂上だから まあ悪くないんですけどね
登る人はアホですけど
まあ登ったっても別に悪くはないんですけど
だって何もないんだから
登ったって で それで原因を変えればいいんですね
それで原因を変えようと構ったところで
登山に訓練しなくちゃいけないし
季節の変化やらね そういういろいろ訓練しなくちゃいけないんですね
ヒマラヤの場合は普通の山とは違いますからね
で かなり訓練が必要なんです
それはやってみようかなと思ったら
自分の年やらね いろんなものと計算しちゃうと
これは無理とわかるでしょうね
やめる やめればいいんです
で あ 自分にとってはその条件だったらなんとかなりますよと思ったら
もうなんとかすれば登れないわけでもないんです
ですから このあれが無理
これが無理というふうに諦めことも
その主義もあまりよくない
やればできるんだよと
でもやれば確実にできるのではなくて
それは因果法則によるものだと
だから因縁を揃うことができれば
まあ何のことなくできますよと
だからいつでも自分の主観というのは
派手に出さないこと いわゆる望む結果っていうのは自分の主観だから
それぐらいにしておいて
こういうふうになればいいなと
それだけに それから自分でやるものではないんだと
他は世の中の原因なんです
それはきちんと論理的に整理してみる
それが仏教的な計画なんです
何か紙の上でいろいろ図を描いたりやいろいろいろいろやってしたっても
そうするとちょっとおかしくはなります
いくら描いて描いて計画を立てても
やっぱり因果法則だから常に調整しなくちゃいけないという
だから予定は狂わないんです
まあ例えば 50人が集まるということであって
そこで50人に食事しなくちゃいけないんだ
それで注文しましたと
注文したところで電話かけてみたら
まだまだなんで弁当来ないんですか？って
その店の人 何？そんな契約受けてないんですけどと
言われるとどんな調子？こちら50人集めて
まあ9時 10時から集めて話し合って 12
時になったところでみんなで弁当を食べて
それから12時半からまた次の会議をやりましょうという決まりだとしましょう
それで11時になっても弁当来る気配はない 11
時半になってもないと
これ心配する それで店に電話してみたところで
店は全然知らないと 言っちゃうとどうなりますかね
みんな狂っちゃうと思いますけど
そういう切羽詰まってる状態というかね
私の人生ではもう結構ありましたけど
いきなりあ どうしようかと
私はその瞬間に じゃあこういうことだから
今はこういうふうに原因を変えればいいんじゃないかなと
すぐ原因を変えるんです
あるいは注文頼んだ人に言って
その人に怒鳴ったりとかね
なんであんたちゃんとやってないんですか？とかね
そんなことではないんです
だから今11時半 弁当は来ないと
で それで私だったら まあ私はちょっとそっち用事があるんだから 30
分抜けますと どうぞやってくださいと言って
なんとか他のことをするんです
走ってそこら辺にある
車でも借り そこら辺にあるいろんな弁当屋さんからね
もうコンビニから集まるか
あるいは何のことなく報告して
実はこういうふうに12時に弁当を食べる予定でしたけど
突然それ取り消しになりましたと
ですから申し訳ないんですけど 12
時になったら皆様方はそこら辺の店に行ってご飯を召し上がってくださいと
もしこちらからあげるだったら
こちらから全部領収書を持ってきたらお金払いますよと
そういうふうに決めましたよ
向こうはこちら狂ってるとわかったらまずいと思ったら
一応その方が皆様は好きなものを食べられますから
こちら金額はこれぐらい
一人千五百円に決めてましたから
その範囲でどうぞご自由に気持ちいくままに召し上がって
一時に集めてください
ありがとうございます
ったらもうバレないでしょうに
だからそれは別に経営が狂ったっていうことは
原因ちょっと変えてみるだけのことなんです
一回自分自分の国でお寺でやるお坊さん
自分のお寺ではないんだけどね
まあ外国からかなりの人気のお坊さんが来るということで
そのお寺の関わるお坊さんですけど
そこでお寺に呼んで もう大きに歓迎会やりますと
で 私はその人にあんたね
ちょっとやめた方がいいんだ
あんまりにも大きなスケールで
これ無理だと とせんと大丈夫
大丈夫 みんなに行ってるんだから
あんたも来てくださいと
そうはちょっと私は心配やと言っても
その人はあまりにも有名な人で
他のところ いろんなところでお歓迎会やってるんだからね
そちらに行って我々も参加すればそれでよそのもんだよと
いえいえ まあもうもともとこのお寺のお坊さんだから
こちらでやらなくちゃ
ああそう じゃあ言うんだったらその日に来ますよ
言ったら このお坊さんがすごい威張って
いろんなところにお坊さんたち呼んでるんです
知ってる人やら友達やら
あっちからこっちから
それでたくさんのお坊さんたちが集まっちゃったんです
でもあのグループの中の人なんです
その人にはなんとか食事はありましたけど
他のお坊さんたちはどうしますか？そのお坊さんが
住職さんが全然 もうもう何ですかね
もうまだ まあまあ 私は言ってるんだけど
まだ来てないんですよ
とか言ったら 他の弟子がいてね
この人は全然やってないんだと
私は全然気にしない 私に関係ないんですけど
私はやっぱり外から来たお坊さんたちにとっては
これ大変な迷惑でしょうに
何のことなく自分に車もありますし
もう一人 あんたの車を貸せと
もう一人人は車貸して
お坊さんみんな車に乗って言ったら
もうみんな まあ私はすごい気楽に言うんだからね
みんな みんな みんな あんた
あんた 乗って乗って乗ってって
そのまま街に連れて行ったんです
と言っても もう一回店に行ってみたんです
そしたらこれイスラム教の店で
で レストランに時半にお祈りするんだから
店を閉めてあったんです
だからお客さんがいないんです
で 向こうはスリランカでお坊さんたちとイスラム教とはそういう仲がもう全くものすごい仲がいいんで
こういうふうにいろいろ批判するんだけど
決して仲が悪いわけじゃないんです
だから何のことなくドアを開けて中に入ったら
みんなあ お坊さんなんでなんですかではなくて
大変なことになります
私はもう三十人のお坊さんたちがいるんだけどね
もう早くご飯作って食べさせなくちゃいかんだけど
あんた方できますか？と
困ってますよ と言ったら
この人 我々のお祈りの時間なんで
だから店は閉めてますけど
一応商売するんだだから食事全部作って用意してはいますけど
それからずっともう夜までやってますからね
用意はしてますけど １０
時１５分 １２時半で店開けますよと
そんなこと言っても私は困りますけどと
言ったら何のことはない
わかりました どうぞどうぞ
みんな来てください 誰もない店でみんなお坊さんに座ってもらって
それで私もまた向こうのことを心配して
でもあんた方お祈りはどうしますかと
言ったら大丈夫 それはもう簡単にやりましたと
やってないと思いますけどね
だからそれもお互い仲がいいんだからね
こちらが心配してるんだから
向こうはちゃんと それはちょっと調整してくれたことで
だからなかなか喧嘩できませんね
お互いに助け合ってますから
で で なんのことなく無事にまあ問題終わって
お坊さんたちにも まあ知ってる人にお坊さんたちにはね
あの坊主野郎ね ぶん殴ってやりたいと言ってんだけど
他のあまり知らないお坊さん
そんなこと言わなかったし
あの で 問題は何のことなくもう解決しました
でないと大変なことになります １
日ももうご飯もなくなっちゃうんだから
遠くから来て 呼ばれて
大人関係っていうのは結構きついものでしょうし
だからそうやって突然もうなんとかなるということは
まあ当然ある その瞬間でちょっと考えて
原因 またちょっと調整してやる
だから私は私もいろいろ計画立てたりしますけど
大体私の一つのずるいことがありますけど
あまり計画は明確に言わない
こういう計画で こういう目的
こういうふうにするんだぞと
なぜかというと そうするとみんな迷っちゃうんです
いくつかまず理解しない
まずできっこはないと
それからあれやこれやと批判ばっかしで
でないと私はまあ原因だけそろって考えてもらって
あなたはこれやってくれますかと
あなたはこれやってくれますか？と言って
そろっそろっと必要になっているところで
かすかに計画の目的の図をかすかに見えるように
薄暗く見えるようにする
それでみんななるほどうまくいったもんだなと
でも私はうまくいくという 100パーセント自信があるわけじゃなくて
原因が変わったらすぐこうします
これ変わったらこうしますと
いくらでもこの選択っていうのは無制限にある
ない場合はないストップと堂々とストップする
例えば何か買おうと思ったところでお金がないと
やめればいいでしょうに
そんなに もう２ ３回やったんです
何か計画を立てて もう日にちもないんだから
何か店に行って ああ この日で行きますよと行ってもう慌ててもう店に行って
じゃあこれ じゃあどうぞちょうだいと言って
はいと言って じゃあお金出すのお金がない
何か言い訳して まあいいわ
まあ今度買いますから
何のことも帰ります だから条件変えることができれば変えちゃう
変えなかったら別に計画はそのままです
ストップになるしか方法ないんだから
それは失敗でも何でもないんだよ
因果法則だから 自分の意見で物事行くわけじゃないし
他人の意見で物事行くわけでもないし
時々この品物はすごくいいものやと言っても
一生懸命店の側が説明しちゃうと
それは買いたくないんだったら
いろいろ条件変えて本人に言わせるんです
そんなろくなものではないと
だからもうそれ知ってるとうまくできるんだ
だからこっち逃げる方法もないしね
こういうことで 私はちょっと見て
この人のいいいい説明
言ってる説明も聞いて
この場合はどうしますかね
これはこうなったらどうします？言ったら向こうがどうしようかなとかね
また困っちゃうんですね
予測してなかったものだから
そうですね やっぱりね
私はそれ そうすると終わり
話が だからまあ ある面で言えば
自分の希望通りに行くといえば希望通りに行くことで
別に自分の希望というものでもなくて
客観的な因果法則を考えれば
計画狂うということは成り立たないんです
だからこのずっとこの神様に恵まれてとかね
特別な守護神に自分が特別に守られてとかね
そんなことを考えちゃうと
人間ダメになるんです
知恵には勝てないんだと
誰でも知恵こそもう武器だと
瞬間瞬間の判断能力こそ人間にとっては武器だと
それには神も恐れますよと思って
きちんと客観的に物事を見て調整しておけば
計画狂うということになるけれども
なぜ私は調整という言葉を使いますかと
それも考えてですね 調整っていうのは初めから終わるまでやるもんなんですよ
調整しまして終わりということはないんです
調整だから だから計画っていうのは固定したものじゃないんです
一旦これいうことやと決めてから
この実行する上で 最初のところに来るまで調整っていうのはずっと必要なんです
車の運転だと思ってみれば
一旦エンジンかけた時から
エンジンかけてギアを入れた時から止まるとこまでずっと調整しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
エンジンかけてギアを入れてアクセルレートを踏む
それで車は動く それで動きますかね
動くのは動くんだけど
そこら辺に壁にぶつかっちゃって死んじゃいますからね
ですから そこから自分の目的ところに行って
車は駐車 駐車してエンジンを切るところまで調整
調整 調整 それを因果 それが因果法則で
それ忘れてはいけません
そうすると狂ったっていうことはないんです
何でも調整 例えば どこかに行こうと思って
自分が真剣真面目に車を運転して行く
自分の原因ではないんだけど
他人の原因で車がぶつかったりします
そうすると目的地に行けないんですね
どうやって調整すればいいんですかね
どこかへ出かけようと用事があって
結婚式でもよろしいし
葬式でもいいんです 葬式がありますと
で 高速道路に行ったところで
なんかどこかから車が滑ってきて
自分の車にバーンとぶつかっちゃったら
調整する人は事故を起こしませんだからね
ですから 厳密に調整する人がいる
因果法則を知っている人がいる
その人はすごい丁寧にちゃんと車を運転して行く
その時でも何か突然何か来てぶつかったりします
それもこの調整が下手なんです
時々の高速道路の事故なんか見てみると
やっぱりみんなダメだなと
大体避ける 避けられるものってものすごい多いんです
時々トラックなんかね
荷物を載せていきなりブレーキかけたりしたら
後ろもの長いから横になったりしますね
そうすると横になっただけでいって
なんで次から次へと車が行ってぶつかるんですかね
みんなどこを見て運転しているんですかと聞きたいんですけど
だから常に調整っていうことを忘れちゃうんです
高速道路だから ただアクセル踏んだままでじーっとバカみたいに見ているんだから
それでもそうやって次から次へとぶつかってぶつかって
だからいつでも前の車に合わせてこちらずっといないと
大体見えますよ 車の後ろ見ると相手の心のまで私には見えますけど
分かりませんですけどね
大体不安定な人か 祈りしているかとかね
凶暴な人かとか 性格まで見えますよ
車の後ろの方を見ても
だからこの人はちょっと乱暴で凶暴やと思ったら
こちらはそれなりに自分で合わせると
そうするとまあスピードもありますから
このブレーキかけて車止まるわけですから
もしかするとぶつかるぐらいのことはあるかもしれませんだけど
そんなにも危険にはならないと思います
とにかく統制っていうのはかなり下手な
だから事故を起こしちゃいますよ
特に日本で事故を起こすこと自体
私はおかしいと思います
これぐらい厳密にすべて整理し
整備してあって それでまたみんなものすごい決まり守ってやってるのに
事故あること自体おかしいんです
それはもう頭が悪いとしか言う方法もないのです
それぐらい全部きちんと計画立ててきちんとできているのに
だから自分の国と比べて言うんです
何一つもないんだから
そんなものは 道路は狭いし
狭い代わりに道路を見えない車ばっかしで
そういうところでも何も誰も決まり守ってないんだからね
高速高速というのは一つも誰も守ってない
だからそこら辺で事故を起こしちゃっても当たり前ということになりますけどね
日本では事故あったらおかしい
とにかくそんな話でもいいんですけど
例えばそうやって葬式に行こうといったところで
高速道路で突然ぶつかってしまったとします
そこで常に物事を調整する人はどうすればいいんですか？と
事故を起こしちゃったらもういけないでしょうに
だから次の調整っていうのは事故の処理なんでしょうに
葬式どうしようと どうでもいい
もうもうもういけない
スト終わり だから気楽でいられます
葬式にももう行けないんだからね
で まあ警察やらいろいろ読んでみましょうと
そこら辺でこういうことで病院に行ったら
じゃあ病院に運びましょうとかね
向こうの車も病院に行ったら
まあもうその何とか助けて
はいはい どうぞどうぞとかね
じゃああんたじっとこちらにいてくださいとか
救急車を呼びますからとかね
そういうそこら辺で調整すれば抜群でしょうね
人生は 例えばまあこれ友人やらその葬式です
ただ 自分がどうしても参加しなくちゃいけない
自分の家のね 誰かの葬式であろうと
私だったらだったら電話ぐらいかけて
こういうことになったんだから
そちらちゃんとやってくださいと
お客さんに失礼だからと一言は言って
別に気にしない 来た方々に失礼だからちゃんとやってくださいと
それで家の人々はそれでも何もできないんだったら
葬儀屋さんがいるんで
その人に電話かけて言うんです
あんたきちんとやりなさい
もう私は来られもう来られませんと
事故を起こしちゃったんだから
だから家の人々は何もわからなくても
もうがっかりしているかもしれません
だからそこら辺ちゃんと面倒見てよと頼みますよと
それで終わります だから解決できないということはありえないんです
だから ブッダというのは
とにかく自分が行かなくちゃいかないとか
そうやってこの自分の自我で物事を考える時なんで
そうでなきゃ別に調整予定来るってありえない
成り立たないんです よって
その場でその場でも原因変わりますから
自分自分の意見で行くわけじゃないんです
冬だったら知らないと
もしどこかちょっと氷でもあったら
見えなかったらどうしますか？滑っちゃうでしょう
その瞬間で じゃあそれだったらこうしますという
だからこの瞬間で判断できるということが
この原因論をきちんと身についている人なんです
ああ 原因が変わったら結果も変わったんだそうと
だから次にどういうふうに原因を調整しますかと
その瞬間で見れればいいんですね
それは仏教の立場から見る計画的な生き方なんです
それであの話は終了したいんですけど
また大体世の中で嫌がるもう一つ話があります
無常の話 それお釈迦様は単純なことを教えてるんだよとか
失礼なことを思うかもしれませんだけど
これがものすごい大事な真理なんです
物事は無常であると 物事も無常だったら計画は立てるわけ
立てくはないでしょと思うでしょうに
無常だから計画立てられます
無常でなきゃ自分が勝手に計画立てたってどうにもならないんです
定めた方向へ行くんだから
物事にももう定めたとくなんともないんです
無常ですから もう次から次へと変化する
ですから 変化する流れを我々にいろいろ条件変えて
流れを少々変えることはできます
それが正しい計画なんです
年は取りたくないんだぞと計画を立てて
いろんなことを食べたり
運動したりしたっても
それは無常に逆らうことであって
成り立たないことです
まあどうしても年取る
それはもう避けられない
無常だからと だから年取る過程をちょっと調整しましょうと
年を取っても まあ寝たきりにならないようにとかね
で 何て言いますか 脳卒何とかね
そういう風にならないようにとかね
心臓の血管が硬くならないようにとかね
それぐらいの調整は不可能ではありません
それで年取ることをやめて
私は 80歳になっても
いや  30代の元気でいたいとかね
言っちゃうと それはあまりにも主観であって
成り立たない 物事はどうしても止まることなく変わっていくんです
変わっていく流れをちょっと変えてみるということはできます
だから 川と同じ 川の流れを止まるということはできません
川の流れを止まっちゃうと
これは大変なことになるんです
大変な危険な結果になります
ですから 私たちには川の流れを好きなように調整はできます
役に立つように 役に立つように川の流れを変えたんだからって
川の流れがなくなるわけじゃないんです
どうせ流れている川だから
こういうふうにちょっと調整した方がちょっと役に立ちますよと
そういうふうなことが正しい計画なんです
ですから 無常ということは大変大事な教えで
これは大事な教えというのは失礼なんです
それが事実であって それが忘れちゃうとすべて狂ってしまっている
それで忘れない人にとっては何も狂うことはないんです
すべて常に無常で変わるんだと
で 変わるんだということを知っている人には
まあ変わり方をちょっと
どうせ変わるんだったら
こういう風にすればどうでしょうかと
例えば子供はどうしても家出したがっている
これはもう変化だからやめられませんね
家にいなさいと言ったっても
子供って大きくなりますからね
まあどうしてももう家出
するんだから だったらあなたはこうすればどうでしょうかと
ちょっと変えてあげればいいんじゃないんです
そうすると自分も子供も安心でしょうに
とにかくもう計画もなしにもうとにかく東京に行くんだとか
なんとかあると それで親がやっぱりあんたも大人だから
もうそろそろ家出した方がいいんだよと言って
まあとりあえずあんた １
年間ぐらいどこか外国で留学でもしたらどうですかね
家出する前に それでどこかに外国の学校に何か話をつけちゃって
自分で行ったらいいけど
それで家出よりは多いんだからね
子供にとっては それで悪くなるわけでもないし
ものすごい心配もあるし
きちんといて それで留学もして
勉強もして 一人前になって
もう帰って一人で生活するようになるんです
それに逆らおうとするんだから
親と喧嘩してとにかく飛び出ていく
本人もどうするか分からなくて
人生どうなるか分からなくなっちゃう
それで両側も心配で不幸になるんです
ですから この変化に逆らうんじゃなくて
変化をちょっと調整してみるということ
それが無常をうまく使う方法なんです
で そうすると決してまた帰ってくるったというね
ことはないんです だからどういう風になってもいいんです
好きにどうする だからもう私の一つの生き方なんですけど
もう何かあったら大変だと思わないんです
何かあった瞬間に私は考えるのは次にどうしますか？と
もう起きたこと もう起きちゃったんだから
ああ 大変だ どうしようということがなくて
じゃあ次にどうしますかと
そうすると悩む暇がないんです
次の何かできること 何なのか
何なのか そこばっかり頭が行くんだから
だからこの無常を知っていると
そういうふうに大変楽に生きていられます
なぜならば 我々生きるということは無常でしょうしね
まあもう生まれた時からずっと変わって変わって生きている
それは生きているということもするし
ご飯を食べたら無常だからご飯消化するし
花が咲くのも花が散るのも両方無常でしょうし
だから無常でなければ何一つも成り立ちませんし
無常でなければこの光も電気も何もないし
無常でなければ私もしゃべることもできないし
皆様に聞くこともできないし
聞いた話を覚えておくこともできないし
だから世の中何一つ成り立ちません
地球も宇宙も何一つも
全てもう常に変化するということで成り立ってるんです
それに逆らうのはもう無知もいいところなんです
永遠ということを思うこと自体も
もう無知の無知なんです
それはもう暗闇なんです
暗黒なんです 永遠永遠
なんとか考えちゃうとありえないんです
だから永遠の天国なんかは
仏教では全然考えてもないんだ
もうあんまりの無知な人を考えることであって
無常に逆らおうと無常に逆らうんじゃないんです
すべて無常なんです 瞬間しかないんです
で その中で一時的にちょっと流れを変えてみるとかね
無常でなきゃ子供には勉強できません
だから子供はどんな学校に入るかということによって
子供の将来は決められるでしょうに
だからそれは無常だからありえることであって
必ずしもこの子は悪い子になるんだよとかね
すごい立派に勉強するんで
そんな決まり定めがないんです
入れた学校を入れた環境はもう変なんだったら変な結果になるし
それなりのしっかりした環境に入れちゃうとしっかりした人になるし
それは無常だからそうなるんです
子供の主観でうまくいくわけじゃないんです
たとえ勉強したくない
もう私はふざけて遊び回りたいと思う人であろうとも
それなりのところに入れちゃえば
じゃあやってみなさいと
できないんですよ もう自分の意見通るわけじゃないんだから
それで立派になります
ですから もう不可能はないんですよ
例えば 我々インド文化系のインド文化系の人々みたいに
子供が生まれたらすぐにもう星を計算して運命を占ってみるんですね
そうすると この子はこうなるんだ
ああなるんだとか インチキなことをいろいろ言うんです
そんなことを信じ込んじゃうとどうにもならんのだから
たとえ占い師はこの子はもう決して勉強には向いてないんだよと言っても
それなりの環境を作っておけば
何のことなく勉強します
だから環境から独立して生きるってことはありえないんです
だから自分の意見というのは通らない
自分の希望なんかは決して叶わないんです
もともと一度でも 未知の過去から未知の未来まで
人の希望っていうのは叶ったことない
そんなもうインチキです
我々はもう誤解しているだけで
これ私の希望が叶ったわけじゃなくて
まあまあ ただまあそういうふうな結果になったんであって
その結果 自分でも望んでいた
それだけのこと あ その結果だったら悪くないなと自分が思うだけのことなんです
希望が叶ったというのは
例えば 人に何かものすごい高額のまあまあもう馬券でも当たったとする
その人は自分の希望が叶ったそうと思ったと
それは勘違いであって
その人の友達に聞いてみてください
あれは悪いことやで それでよかったねと思いますから
そうすると友達の希望も叶ったことになるでしょう
だから たまたま起きた出来事は自分から見れば悪くないと
その方がいいということに希望が叶ったと勘違いする
希望叶うということは成り立たないことで
一つの原因にはなりますけど
それなりに条件揃えばまあうまくいく可能性はいくらでもありますということで
ですから 無常ということも
ものすごい真剣に生きる哲学にしないと
明るく生きていられません
無常に逆らっちゃうと大変なことになる
例えば計画狂ったんだからといって落ち込む人っていうのは
無常に逆らおうとしているだけ
まあそんなもん狂っちゃいますよと
狂っちゃえばこうすればいいんじゃないかと思えば
それだけで問題は解決する
そういうことだから たとえ家が火事になっても悲しくなる必要はないんです
家が火事になんで悲しくなるの？もう家に住めないんだから
次に夜寝るところ探せばいいでしょうに
今日はどこに寝ればいいかと
次にどうするべきかということだけ考えれば
友人がいるならば 親戚がいるならばそちらに行く
で なければそこら辺の旅館
ホテルでも行くとか 次のこと必ずもありますからね
それ無常と同時に 今日時間はないんですけど
この時間論というのを覚えた方がいいんですね
時間というのは時間はないんだけど
時間というものはないんだけど
あるのは現象ですけど
現象というのは止まることなく変化するんだということは
仏教の時間論なんです
それはもうもうどうにもならんことで
もう一つは時間論でいうのは
例えば米をご飯になるまでは30分かかりますね
いくら我々は急いでいたっても
米を洗って水を入れて炊飯器に入れてスイッチを入れちゃうと
もう30分ぐらいかかったところでちゃんと食べられる美味しいご飯が出来上がる
それはもう巻きで もうものすごいモーレスな
を炊いて もう釜で焼いていてもご飯にはなりません
ただ焼けてしまうだけ
炭になるかもしれません
ですから たとえ薪でご飯を炊いても
もう分以上かかるということは決まってます
それでも減ることも延ばすこともできない
それから保存時間を見ても
例えば米だったら年ぐらいでも保存状態によって食べられます
悪くならない でもご飯になったら日以内で食べないと
もう食べるものにならないんです
今は冷蔵庫とかいろいろあるんだから
もうもうちょっと冷凍庫に入れちゃえば持ちますけど
冷凍庫に入れたっても
これは年持てるということはないんです
せいぜいヶ月間ぐらいですからね
ですから なんで米は年持てるのに
ご飯は日だけですか やっぱりご飯にはご飯の時間がある
米には米の時間があるということは
米という現象が食べられる現象としている時間なんですね
それでまあ 店から大根買って豆腐買ってきます
大根は来週でも食べられます
買ってきた豆腐は今日食べないと
そういう風に各物に これはもうあまり正しい言葉じゃないんだけど
各現象が自分の時間を持っています
いわゆるその現象が変化する時間ですよ
違うものになる時間 それはもうどうにもならんこと
じゃあ電気のスピードを速くすることできますか？もっと早く電気を流しておこうかなとか
できませんね そういうふうにできません
ですから 人生慌てる必要ないんです
慌てるのは この時間のわからない
無常わからない人なんです
綺麗に自然に全部流れているんです
こちらがいくら嫌がっても
もうまあ五十五を飛んじゃったんだからね
なるべきものは綺麗になるんです
そんな慌てたっても焦ったっても
何の意味もないんです
ですから この計画やら何やらね
そんなことを考えたっても
現象がその現象の時間に応じて動いているんだと
それに自分の欲望を出しちゃって苦労必要はないんだと
その中で生きている人
その現象だから どう調整すればいいかなと
それだけ覚えておけばいいんです
買ってきた豆腐は日にで食べられなくなりますけど
それでも今日は食べられませんと
明日も出かけますから食べられないんだと思っちゃうと
でも捨てるのはもったいないんだと思ったら
どうしますか  火を通す
それもその方法ですけど
それでも悪くなっちゃう可能性もあるしね
まあなんとか方法でまあ
保存するようにしておけばね
あるいは水をギューっともうもう切って
溝の中にでも置いておけば
悪くならないんですけど
で もうそのまま食べられるし
まあどうでもいいんですけど
とにかくまあ 焼いておくか揚げておくか
どちらでもいいんですけど
まあなんとかすればっていう
そういうふうなことでね
だから何かの調整はできます
何の調整もできないものは
まあ諦めるんですよ それはものすごい自然なんです
じゃあ 自分の台所にあるガラスを
もうカップを割れたとします
どうしますか？その時は
泣く もう割れちゃったんだから諦めるでしょうに
そのままゴミ箱に入れるでしょうに
だからもうどうにもならないことはすぐ諦める
それは常にやっていますから
なんでそれは人生哲学に持ってこないんですかね
なんであれだけはどうっても諦め諦められませんとか言って悩むんで
それはバカバカしいでしょうに
カップが割れちゃったら平気に捨てるんだから
諦めちゃって 服が破れちゃったらもう平気で諦めるでしょうに
時々美味しそうに弁当持って行って
もう公園で食べようと思っても
もうもう口まで運ぶ これが美味しい
だして ふとんと落ちちゃうんです
落ちちゃうとまた拾って
それはないでしょうに
もう諦めるそれを それ食べられないんだけど
やっぱりあのエビ食べたかったんだ
もう私にとってはすごく好物でしたのとか
それは無知バカでしょうに
だから物事っていうのは
もうもう終わったものはすぐ諦める
豆腐はやっぱり捨てたい
捨てるのもったいないなと思ったら
だったらなんとか調整する
調整はありえないんだったら
もうポイント捨てるだけのことでしょうに
ですから 無常っていうのは大変なこの生き
もう元気で明るく活発に生きるために忘れてはいけない事実なんです
世の中の哲学はそれを忘れようとしているんです
だから仏教はちょっと凶暴で忘れるなよと
忘れたらバカになるんだよと
バカになってはいいんだけど
不幸になるんだからね
ですから 忘れてはいけませんと
それで当然なことに この自我が良くない
当たり前でしょ 自我っていうのは自分の意見を通ってほしいと思ったんだから
だから 1 日も生きていられません
一つも自分の希望通りにいかなくなっちゃいますから
自我がない人にとっては
もう何でもうまくいきますし
あまり欲張ってはいけないとかね
欲張るということはまるっきり主観でしょうに
そうすると心が硬くなるんです
自分の欲で これやりたい
これやりたいだけで 周りの条件
原因見えなくなっちゃうんです
それから怒るなよと 怒ったら心がピシッと硬くなっちゃうんです
石になっちゃうんです
もう何も調整効かないんです
人生はもうずっと調整だから
石で石頭ではもう終わり
ですから 欲 わがまま 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみとか そういうものが入っちゃうと
もうもう周り見えなくなっちゃって
頭が硬く石になっちゃうんです
それでもはっきりと不幸なんです
永久的に調整 調整 調整で人生はもう運転するんだぞということはなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 仏教ではこの怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ 欲などなどなどというのはね
まあ僧害の煩悩がね 良くないと言っているのは
まあこれは幸福のために
そんなものを私から見れば当たり前の話で
怒ってみてください 何がうまくいくんでしょうかと
たとえ人が悪いことをしたっても
怒らないで落ち着いて見てみてください
うまくいきますから この失敗は損にならないようにすることはできますから
怒ったら失敗の上に損にもなりますから
ですから ありとあらゆる煩悩っていうのは良くないんだと
煩悩で汚染されちゃうと必ずしも不幸になる
体も壊れるか 健康もなくなる
みんなに嫌われる 一つも希望通りにいかない
そもそも希望を作ったことを間違いしね
だから怒り 欲がある人が
私のこれが希望やとかね
思ったりもするし そういうことだから
このたとえもうどんなことがあっても
穏やかで幸福で楽しく
あ うまくいってるんだという気持ちで生きているためには
まあそこら辺で柔らかい心が必要なんです
いつでも調整効く心が必要なんですね
それがこのまず人々に対して慈しみが生まれてくると
そうすると自分という主観が消えちゃう
みんな同じという気持ちになっちゃうと
それからやっぱり仏教で言ってる
この禅というね 欲が少なく
怒りがなく 嫉妬もなく
清らかな心で生きてみると
なぜ心が柔らかくなります
すごい柔軟性になります
そのその場で その場で
その 適応するようになるんですね
だから適応できないなったらまあ終わりでしょう
環境に適応できなかったら生きていられないしね
それで人生についてあっても
その瞬間 その瞬間に適応できるかないかと
その瞬間に適応できることに智慧というんです
特別にもっと覚えておく知識ではありません
瞬時に現れてくる だったらこうしますということは
だから次どうするべきかという
この問答というかね そのそれを頭の中に入れておくと
いつでも次にどうすればいいかと
まあ智慧が一応出てきますと思います
では 話はそこら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]